these are the strongest devil fruits in
one piece the Tremor Tremor fruit was
eaten by Whitebeard and it enabled him
to create powerful shock waves that can
travel through anything including the
ground the sea and even the air the bird
bird fruit model Phoenix was eaten by
Marco and it allows him to transform
into the legendary phoenix as well as a
phoenix human hybrid it can also heal
people the dark dark fruit was eaten by
Blackbeard and it enables him to create
and manipulate Darkness itself it seems
to also allow its user to steal other
devil fruits the op fruit was eaten by
Trafalgar law and it enables him to
create a space within which he can
manipulate literally anything with
surgical Precision finally the human
human fruit model Nika was eaten by
Luffy and it allows him to harness the
power of imagination even when that
means defying the laws of nature
subscribe to anime uproar for more
one-piece videos